bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui s'adresse à tous même à
ceux qui ne savent pas compter jusqu'à 5
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la 5g
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de ses cages c'est la prochaine
évolution en matière de
télécommunications après la 4g que nous
utilisons aujourd'hui la 5g est à nos
portes qu'est ce que la 5g va changer
dans nos quotidiens quelle différence
par rapport à la 4g
quelles perspectives économiques la 5g
va-t-elle nous offrir ce sont des
questions que nous allons à nous poser
aujourd'hui avec vous olivier mais pour
commencer qu'est ce que la 5g comment ça
marche et que va-t-elle changer dans
notre quotidien le point avec le tiroir
cash d'antoine d'assas la 5 g sega
cinquième génération de réseaux mobiles
jusqu'à 100 fois plus rapides que notre
actuel 4g la promesse d'une quasi
instantanéité lors d'une connexion
concrètement cela ouvre à la traduction
simultanée
la multiplication des objets
interconnecté où l'avenir de la
robotique
vous pourrez peut-être bientôt regarder
ses cages dans une telle définition que
vous pourrez voir jusqu'où petit cheveu
du kram d'olivier de la marche
kenyatta extra-large ans l'été où la
bombe et tué dire quelle europe c'est
pour les cours et après
la violence et de la guerre la 5g passe
par des ondes à haute fréquence peu
utilisé jusqu'à présent essentiellement
par l'armée mais qui vont être ré
attribuées aux opérateurs plus la
fréquence des ondes est haute plus avec
son rapide mais moins leur surface
d'émission est large forçant donc la
multiplication des antennes relais pour
leur diffusion
selon une étude du cabinet ihs hs markit
la 5g pourrait rapporter 3600 milliards
de dollars et 22,3 millions d'emplois
dans le monde d'ici 2035
en france ce serait 124 milliards de
dollars et 448 mille emplois et qu'est
ce qu'on peut en attendre qu'un cas bien
battu médias estelle alors 448000 emploi
vous ont mis deux filles ont été
récoltés suite prévoient la croissance
qu'on veut avant l'année prochaine
alors passez me bats et chi freight se
pose aussi la question d'un éventuel
danger pour la santé l' agence nationale
de sécurité sanitaire a pointé dans un
rapport le manque d'informations voir
nous quasi en facilité sur les
conséquences sur le long terme d'une
exposition à ces ondes 5 g/l super avec
des chiffres comme ça encore assez
dangereux ou pas on n'en sait rien faire
au mieux le faire et pape sy jr là tu
vas directeur olivier c'est une
révolution la singer on peut parler de
révolution sûrement on peut parler de
révolution mais ce qu'il faudrait déjà
excusez moi mais ça serait bien qu'on
ait la 4g partout avant de penser à
mettre la 5g et puis secundo j'ai quand
même une question c'est est-ce que la 5g
doit s'adresser à tout le monde c'est à
dire que je vois bien quelques
applications qui peuvent intéresser une
partie de la population mais sur six
mois enfin télécharger un film plus vite
qu est ce que ça va vous apporter dans
les faits à part peut-être
téléchargez plus vite la vidéo de
monsieur griveaux mais sinon je vois pas
bien si vous voulez l'intérêt alors je
le vois pour des chirurgiens qui
pourront opérer à distance je le vois
pour d'autres applications
mais est-ce qu'on pourrait pas réservé
sa à des applications bien précise
plutôt que vouloir absolument le mettre
à disposition de tout le monde sachant
que ça va demander des investissements
colossaux et pour un retour qui va être
probablement pour une grande partie de
la population très faible en matière
d'économie ça peut aussi nous apporter
de nouvelles perspectives par exemple 4
146 mille emplois en france alors 448000
emploi vous oubliez tout de suite parce
que ça ce genre de prévisions si vous
vous laisser on n'est déjà pas fichu de
prévoir la croissance qu'on va avoir
l'année prochaine alors ne n'imaginais
pas une demi-seconde que ces chiffres
soient d'une quelconque certitude ça
parce que ça veut rien dire si vous
voulez ccc à la cuillère et on vous
seront vous serine ce genre de
prévisions depuis des années sur plein
de secteurs et ça n'a jamais fonctionné
donc ça fera une pression de plus à
mettre à la poubelle
incapable capable de mesurer les
avantages en termes d'emploi alors en
plus si vous voulez quand vous avez
quelque chose comme ça qui va vous
permettre paraît-il de faire fonctionner
des voitures autonomes et c'est
justement ça va faire des gens dehors
qui n'auront plus de raison d'être
puisque vous n'aurez pas de chauffeur de
taxi mais vous aurez vous aurez personne
pour conduire la voiture donc enfin
c'est ce genre de prévision et de toute
façon caduc le joël sort merci à
beaucoup olivier on passe à la deuxième
partie de cette émission et pour
continuer à parler de la 5g on reçoit
carlos bader directeur de recherches à
l'iss up l'institut supérieur
d'électronique de paris
car en ce bel air merci à beaucoup à
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bienvenue dans ces caches
c'est moi qui ai ri devenir merci vous
couvrir vitesse claude bader l'arrivée
de la série g est ce qu'on peut parler
de révolution
techniquement oui on peut parler de
révolution
maintenant comment ça va se déployer sur
le terrain c'est autre chose et
techniquement oui c'est une révolution
donc c'est la première fois vraiment
dans l'évolution des télécommunications
que la 5g
si on peut l'appeler c'est de cette
manière là c'est la première fois que
l'humanité déploie un système de
communication aussi flexible on en a
jamais conçu un système pareil
donc on peut faire un petit peu
l'historique de toutes les générations
la première génération évidemment je
suis encore assez assez vieux entre
guillemets pourquoi avoir connu la
première la première génération donc
c'est les téléphones analogiques
celle qui était vraiment gigantesque
centimes comme le vivent voilà avec qui
pesait et qui peut indiquer 10 kg et il
avait des limitations des limitations
techniques surtout des interférences de
la portée après il faut il faut avoir en
tête pour que pour chaque génération est
ce qu'on appelle les techniciens il faut
il faut qu'elle soit accompagnée d'un
killer application
ça veut dire développer une application
qui fait le boom et son acceptation au
niveau du puits de grand public car la
2g ça a été court ça a été les sms ça a
été révolutionnaire envoyé des petits
messages et petit texto d'un bout à
l'autre
c'était le killer application de
l'époque à la 3g et avait un autre
concept il y avait le concept d'internet
avec la révolution du wifi et en plus la
mobilité du téléphone alors à l'époque
on parlait en parler sur la convergence
mobile fixe ça veut dire qu'à l'époque
quand vous rentrez à la maison que vous
avez du goût du wifi votre système
switcher sur le wifi qu'on vous sortez à
l'extérieur c'était une communication
vers les stations de base cellulaire
alors c'était la convergence
on pouvait y avoir de l'internet avec un
certain débit acceptable révolutionnaire
pour l'époque et aussi de la mobilité
vous pouviez vous promener dehors avec
emilie mans de débit à l'extérieur après
la kadji qu'est ce que c'est la 4g et
ballack a dit la grande révolution c'est
que le prix des rames et des
microprocesseurs et danse descendu dans
le marché ce qui a fait ce qu'on a pu
mettre sur les téléphones portables
aujourd'hui qu'on appelle 4g un
ordinateur ça veut dire que votre mobile
a vous a exactement le même professeur
processeur que n'importe quel
ou ordinateur que vous pouvez voir à
l'extérieur donc ça a donné une force de
computing ce qu'on appelle techniquement
et c'est ça qui a permis aussi
d'augmenter le grand débit de la 4g et
c'est pour ça aujourd'hui on peut avoir
vous avez la kadji donc il faut il faut
connaître aussi que d'une génération à
une autre génération
il ya des évolutions ce qui modifie
exactement le concept de 2,4 g à st jean
ce qui le rend différent c'est que pour
la première fois à la 5 g c'est un
système de communication qui travaillent
pas seulement que dans la communication
cellulaire telle qu'on l'a connue
aujourd'hui le téléphone avec les
stations de base cellulaire mais vous
allez dire je peux vous dire qu'on vous
habillez vous avez un costume de même
couleur
de même voilà de même de même tissu
banassac si c'est autre chose c'est une
veste en tergal c'est une c'est un
pantalon jeans donc ce qu'on appelle en
jargon technique la couche physique est
constitué de différents types de
communication qui doivent se fusionner
ensemble ça veut dire vous pouvez parler
et aussi avoir une communication d'haïti
ce qu internet of things sévèrement les
objets connectés vous pouvez les objets
connectés ça peut être des objets
connectés avec une contrainte de latence
ça peut être sans contrainte de latence
vous avez vos compteurs maintenant ils
vous envoient des outils mais vous
pouvez le faire la nuit quand le trafic
de communications est le plus bas c'est
à dire il n'y a pas urgence
donc nous avons aussi d'autres
technologies comme le débat est de vases
ou le terminal à terminal ça veut dire
maintenant ce jeu de vous faire un appel
actuellement techniquement avec la salle
4g ma communication vanessa sans base
qui vous cherche dans toute la ville et
qui revient vers vous pour coincer le
téléphone sonne et c'est un peu
excusez moi le terme un peu stupide
parce que vous êtes tout juste à côté de
moi
alors si je veux lancer une
communication le plus intelligent de
produits efficacité énergétique et dieu
et du cycle danic c'est d'avoir une
communication directe avec vous sans
passé avec une grande communication à
travers les stationnements ce type de
communication et ce type d'applications
c'est des choses révolutionnaires qui
vont s'incruster sur la 5g et donc la 5g
dire c'est une combinaison de beaucoup
d'application avec des contraintes
spécifiques et différentes qui doivent
coexister ensemble olivier une réaction
à ces explications
je n'ai rien à dire au niveau technique
mais mais est-ce que ça s'adresse à tout
le monde
est ce que réellement on en a besoin
tous ça c'est une première question la
deuxième question qui est induite par
celle là c'est est ce que on a bien
mesuré toute la dépense énergétique de
nouveaux terminaux de nouvelle
implantation de relais puisqu'il paraît
qu'il en faut beaucoup puisque les les
laisons de son arrêté par n'importe quel
obstacle que ce soit un arbre ou ou un
mur et que donc ça va poser des
problèmes notamment de mettre des relais
beaucoup plus nombreux que aujourd'hui
sur la sur laquelle j'ai donc voilà face
j'ai l'impression quand même qu'on sait
qu'on s'est lancé là dedans alors je
comprends l'intérêt je comprends
l'intérêt aussi pour certaines
applications est vraiment certaines
applications
est ce que aujourd'hui le monde entier a
besoin de la 5g pour son boulot pour son
pour vivre et c'est signé entre à
attendre trois secondes pour charger ou
même une minute pour charger un film et
attendre une seconde je m'en fiche
complètement ça va pas changer ma vie
donc voilà j'ai la question vraiment
c'est celle là pour moi allons allons
pas partie des gants donc sur la chaîne
chez vous avait parlé de deux relais et
antennes il faut comprendre que le
déploiement de la 5g va se faire sur
deux phases sur deux bandes distinctes
la première bande c'est une bande qui
est en dessous de 6 giga et donc la 5g
va être dans la bande de fréquence 2
points 5 gigas 2.4 quelque chose autour
de la et bien quand vous voyez la
différence du déplacement de la scène
j'ai elle n'est pas très loin de la 4g
parce que la 4g c'est 2.2 2.1 donc
quelques méga au dessus il va y avoir de
différence de déploiement et de
contamination tels que vous dites sur
cette bande là maintenant il faut bien
instruire les gens qui nous regardent et
leur donner le maximum d'informations
d'abord dans laquelle vous parlez où il
peut y avoir probablement parce
qu'encore c'est une banque qui va pas se
déployer encore pour la cgc laborde audi
2 si jega ce qu'on n'a pas un appel la
bande millimétriques
alors cette bombe millimétriques
pourquoi on a besoin d'aller sur ces
bandes là parce qu'on veut le futur de
la 5 6 cd des systèmes de communication
à très très très haut débit et pour
avoir de très très haut débit il vous
faut des bandes de fréquences très large
ces bandes de fréquences très large ne
se trouve pas actuellement
là où la 5g va se déployer pour le moins
pour les débits que nous voulons ok donc
pour ces bandes à ses banques qui sont
entre 23-25 gigahertz
ok c'est bon cela qu'on appelle les
bandes millimétriques pour ses bandes
millimétriques effectivement qu'est-ce
qui est en visionner là-dessus cdc des
taux de débit qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
du 100 gigabits par seconde et même plus
haut que ça ok donc on part des
applications qui sont très très très
très forte
pour vous c'est pas important de
télécharger une vidéo mais probablement
où vous savez que l'industrie du jeu par
exemple qui bouge des milliards et des
milliards
si vous voulez faire de jeux interactive
virtuel à 100 giga par seconde avec des
publics qui joue il ya un marché pour ça
je dis seulement cet exemple là et donc
il faut faire attention c'est cette
bande là dans laquelle encore
physiquement et matériellement les
industries travail il ya encore des
problèmes techniques
maintenant si vous voulez que l'on part
sur l'interférence électromagnétique qui
est pareil que les genres thibault et à
une alerte là dessus on va on va
reparler assez des problèmes éventuels
de 1,5 g danemark une courte pause et on
revient dans un instant non non c'est
cash si vous nous rejoignez on parle de
la 5g avec carlos bader directeur de
recherche à l'isepp l'institut supérieur
d'électronique de paris
carlos wagner une question que tout le
monde se pose est ce que c'est dangereux
la salle j ok d'accord il faut il faut
il faut calmer les esprits au quai donc
j'en ai vu pas mal de rapports et donc
je veux dire qu'il n'ya pas de bon de
chercheurs et de mauvais chercheurs il
faut que les chercheurs communiquent
entre eux les industriels les
académiciens et les gens et les
organismes de la santé effectivement
donc je pense pour la 5g la banque qui
causent le plus de la litière de pas de
problème et qui causent plus de
d'inquiétude c'est pas la bande actuelle
dans laquelle la 5g va être déployée
parce que
tout est ficelé et les mesures de
radiation sont quasiment très proche de
la 4g de contrôle très bien ça donc je
pense la bande qui cause un peu de
d'alarmé c'est la bande au dessus de 6
giga celle qu'on appelle la bande
millimétriques donc pour de cette bande
de dimitri quand les gens font des tests
on peut vous dire effectivement j'ai un
téléphone qui radient sur une claquette
d'oeuvre pendant une semaine et vous
allez avoir un petit coucou qui va
sortir avec des malformations donc les
ondes électromagnétiques et sont
dangereuses c'est vrai effectivement on
est d'accord là dessus seulement est ce
que c'est un business case réaliste qui
se met un téléphone dans l'oreille
pendant une semaine full time
peu après les gens de la bourse new
yorkaise où la bourse londonienne
peut-être ils doivent penser deux fois à
mettre un téléphone tout le temps dans
leurs oreilles donc c'est pas réellement
un business case réel de testing et
qu'il ya beaucoup de fantasmes
finalement autour de la salle j non mais
non il ya des craintes c'est tout à fait
normal chaque fois quand sont une
technologie à des craintes mais surtout
les craintes c'est parce qu'il ya un
manque d'information est probablement un
manque de collaboration
donc les chercheurs il faudrait qu'ils
collaborent plus avec les instituts les
instituts et aussi je fais appel aux
organismes de régulation à faire des
études réel sous cette bande là parce
que c'est vrai qu'il va y avoir des
antennes de relais
on parle beaucoup de ce cap elle ramène
la 5g c'est l'ultra connectivité donc
quand vous prenez un objet connecté qui
va qui va rayonner et causent pas
problème donc ce business e caisse de
testing aussi n'est pas réaliste
si on va vers une convergence de de
connectivité ultra connectivité il
faudrait avoir un caisse de testing avec
ça et pour le moment cette bande n'est
pas déployer les équipements encore elle
sans soute s il ya beaucoup de problèmes
techniques
mais je fais appel aux tous d'organismes
et même les organismes d'état pour
régulariser ça et faire des études
neutre parce que c'est vrai il ya
toujours polémique quand c'est les
grands opérateurs avec des industriels
qui font ce genre de rapport en disant
ils sont pas neutres effectivement ils
défendent en s'équipant donc l'état doit
jouer ce rôle-là de régulateur et de
neutralité pour qui et qui est des
études qu'il faut et il n'y a pas de
problème si réellement il ya problème
avec les
sur les radiations sur la population et
d'un nous avons de bons ingénieurs pour
trouver des solutions et que ça soit pas
et il faut le détecter et d'une manière
aussi sobre possible voilier un mot sur
le volet économique les 5 g pour le
moment là vu que la chine était en
avance avec huawei où en sont les états
unis et l'europe
moi c'est un match américano chinois
alors je sais que notre thierry breton a
récemment communiqué la tum enfin pour
l'instant l'europe est et trois pas en
arrière et c'est un match
américain dossier chinois et la presse
et c'est les deux les deux
superpuissances agissent pour pour
prendre la maîtrise et donc au final
savoir si vous équiperez en équipements
américains ou en équipements chinois
c'est exactement comme aujourd'hui est
ce que vous voulez très écouté par les
chinois avec un wayne ou est-ce que vous
vous être écouté par un américain avec
les apple faisait à peu près le meuble
même le même système qui qui va gagner
j'en ai aucune idée je sais que pour
l'instant les européens ont refusé de
de de répondre aux diktats de monsieur
trump qui disait que si on utilisait
ouais ouais c'était terminé
voilà après
je pense que le le aujourd'hui les
chinois sont très en avance c'est un
fait on parlait de l'afp
d'ailleurs la 4g la singer pardon en
france est pour quand ben c'est dans
quelques années déjà il faut il faut
mettre en vente le spectre d'autres pays
européens ont fait ça l'espagne a fait
ça l'italie a fait ça et après quelques
polémiques en italie parce que ça a
coûté 5 milliards d'euros l'achat du
spectre donc à la question aussi des
revenus mais bon mes séances est en
train de se déployer donc c'est imminent
sur sur jallet commenté sur la guerre
sino américaines la question qu'il faut
se poser les premièrement c'est pas de
voir les américains et les chinois
mais pourquoi l'europe est arrivé à ce
stade là voilà pourquoi l'europe est
dans une position assez délicate par
rapport aux états unis et le chinois
oui elle est à la traîne et c'est vrai
et la traîne parce que il ya dix ans et
moi j'étais jeune encore chercheurs à
madrid dans mon laboratoire aux années
90 jusqu'à 2000 jusqu'à 2005 l'europe
avec des constructeurs g aux mondiaux
d'équipé équipementiers de
télécommunications il y avait et
glissant il y avait nos cas le poids de
nokia il y avait en france sagem avaient
alcatel et tout le monde construisez ça
veut dire nous avions des champions
constructeur de des vases soit du
network du réseau soit du des téléphones
portables donc mon analyse c'est plus
qu'un aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'à
aujourd'hui on est à la traîne nokia
invite yvan nokia de secteur nokia
mobile qui passez au chinois mettant il
ya nokia networking sur le réseau qui
essayent de rattraper tout ce retard par
rapport aux chinois et donc c'est ça qui
a fait que la france ou bien l'europe
comme entité est à la traîne c'est pas
parce que nous n'avons pas de bons
ingénieurs nous avons les meilleurs
ingénieurs du monde
mais voilà mais ils vont travailler aux
états unis non non c'est pas vrai non
non non non non je m'excuse ils
travaillent pas ce manque aux etats-unis
travaillent partout dans le monde et là
on les sollicite c'est à dire si notre
goût venons vais mettre du pognon sur la
table pour contrer huawei ou ou
construire d'autres centres de recherche
les chercheurs en premier de ce pays-là
et l'excellence de ce sur ce pays là
seraient les premiers à applaudir
voilà mais alors je vous le dis en tant
qu'économiste
on n'a pas de pognon donc et donc je
l'enjeu n'est pas seulement de pognon le
l'enjeu et technologiques et tout ce qui
va avec
donc donc quand vous parlez des
équipementiers
c'est vrai il ya une division européenne
par exemple l'espagne a fait le choix
des kits de tout en écopant thé chinois
la france est mitigé ça veut dire c'est
vrai qu'il faut être stratégique on peut
pas exclure la chine du futur on est
tous conscients que du point de vue
technologique la chine sera un
partenaire donc on doit faire attention
à nos comportements et à nos contrats
etc stratégique donc on peut pas
l'exclure - canon week end d'ailleurs on
a beaucoup entendu parler sans verser
dans le comté souvent accusé wade est ce
que c'est plausible
je veux vous dire donc il faut il faut
mais écoutez à des choses même en
technologie en sciences ne sont pas
binaire ça veut dire à l'un ou le zéro
le vrai ou le mal le blanc ou le haut le
noir cédé beaucoup d'internationaux
grille ok donc on peut commencer
on peut dire aussi que les états unis ce
que reprochent les états unis hawaii
s'est réellement des pratiques l'a fait
elle même pendant des années ça veut
dire les états unis ont espionné où je
pouvais voir à wikileaks et vous avez
toute la liste de comment on fait de
l'espionnage sur de l'iphone de
l'espionnage sur un samsung smarttv donc
de vous avez tout tout tout tout le
listing donc les états unis valve a
accusé la chine de choses que elle-même
peut faire ou a fait maintenant pourquoi
on n'est pas d'accord avec la chine
parce que vous vous souvenez le fameux
mobile de madame merkel qui coûtait 4000
euros qui a été espionnée par les états
unis est complètement décortiqué donc le
grand problème de la chine
même si on fait tous de l'espionnage
sais que c'est pas un allié et c'est ça
le gros problème
ça veut dire les chinois font la même
chose de ce que nous faisons le problème
c'est que c'est pas un allié et le
système judiciaire chinois n'est pas le
système judiciaire occidental donc il ya
toujours ce flou ce doute
si c'est vrai ou pas vrai et le système
chinois où la compagnie huawei on
connaît qu'il est très proche du système
chinois et on connaît comment le système
chinois et on connaît comment la subtile
et la justice et
probablement c'est vrai et probablement
c'est pas vrai mais il n'y a rien qui
rassure et donc comme il n'y a rien qui
rassure et c'est pas à na li
il ya toujours ce doute là doute il faut
dire justifie aussi solide et une
relation pas écouté en fait on préfère
se faire se faire espionner par un allié
moi je vois pas bien le l'avantagent
qu'on a à permettre aux états unis de
nous espionner gentiment le seul
problème c'est que vous avez aujourd'hui
le système judiciaire
d'extraterritorialité américaine qui
fait que toutes nos entreprises trembles
le cac alstom on l'a vu et d'autres qui
font que nos entreprises sont à la merci
de la justice américaine donc évidemment
on a la trouille de s'élever contre les
américains contre les chinois c'est un
petit peu plus facile parce qu'on a
moins de d'implication et aujourd'hui on
a moins d'entreprises qui sont engagés
on chine parce que on y va sur la pointe
des pieds etc
donc il est évident pour l'instant
l'europe qui est là pour le coup faible
et qui ne se se regroupe pas pour avoir
une décision vis-à-vis des etats-unis et
autres on voit madame merkel qui
agissait en disant oh faut surtout pas
les contrarier et c'est donc un vous
n'avez pas une unité de décision face
aux américains donc on les laisse faire
absolument ce qu'ils veulent et on a un
petit peu plus de difficulté un petit
peu plus de retenue vis-à-vis de la
chine moi je veux pas rentrer dans le
couloir de l'espionnage pas l'espionnage
c'est pas qu'on se laisse gentiment
espionner c'est que nous aussi gentiment
en espionne nous allons donc
donc c'est une hausse entre tout le
monde il ya manière de faire et c'est
pas notre domaine d'aujourd'hui mais bon
et donc donc ce que je voulais dire
c'est vrai la position de là
de l'europe est faible sur
l'équipementier donc nokia actuellement
travaillent jour et nuit pour rattraper
le retard du point de vue technologique
la même chose qu'avec qualcomm et
qualcomm les américains ils sont ils
sont plus prêts hier la présidente de la
commission européenne a fait un appel en
disant que l'artificiel intelligence ou
l'ail est un est une thématique
stratégique pour l'europe et que nous
pouvons gagner encore et nous sommes à
temps de le gagner
donc il ya un appel sur ce sujet là donc
ce qui est ce qui est formidable on
recherche et jeudi c'est toujours à mes
étudiants ou dans les systèmes de
technologie c'est que c'est des trains
qui passent il faut plus rester dans la
défense il ya tant la défensif
il n'y a pas de limite dans
l'imagination et la création elle peut
être en europe ou ailleurs on n'a pas
peur de l'affronter nous avons de très
bons ingénieurs et ce sera le mot de la
fin merci à beaucoup carlos bader
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous et
je rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'isepp l'institut supérieur
d'électronique de paris
exactement merci le chiffre a de la
semaine olivier 150 à 200 millions
d'euros c'est ce que pourrait coûter le
coronavirus à air france klm
un manque à gagner suite à la suspension
de ses vols vers la chine de février à
avril finalement à olivier ans le
coronavirus on le voit à des impacts sur
certains secteurs de l'économie est ce
que est ce que l'aviation est touché
mais ce que d'autres secteurs pourraient
aussi être impactées
vous aurez d'autres secteurs qui seront
impactées maintenant c'est aussi un
excellent prétexte 1
à une ralentissement qui étaient déjà là
avant c'est à dire que vous regardez le
commerce mondial le commerce illégal ça
toute l'année 2019 il a il a reculé et
maintenant on vous dira oui mais c'est
celle à chinon c'était avant le japon a
publié son son quatrième trimestre avec
des chiffres de pib qui sont ahurissants
à -6% on a on a essayé de coller
certains éditorialistes ont essayé de
coller les -6% à la crise du corps
navires us ça n'est pas le coronavirus
puisque il est depuis le début de
l'année et non pas sur le t4 donc c'est
vrai il va y avoir certains secteurs qui
sont touchés par un ralentissement
il faut espérer juste sur un trimestre
ça a l'air de se calmer beaucoup je
pense qu'on en a fait aussi un peu des
tonnes parce que il faut quand même se
rappeler que même si vous multipliez le
chiffre de décès par 10 en chine
ça n'est jamais que deux fois la grippe
annuelle en france 1 il ya dix mille
morts aujourd'hui en france par an sur
le sur la grippe
donc on est à 2000 déclaré en chine donc
vous x par
par 10 et vous avez vingt mille
décès et par 5 par 5 aces par dix même
par disent vous êtes à vingt mille décès
c'est à dire le double de la france pour
un pays qui fait 1 milliard 400 millions
d'habitants donc on est très très loin
de quelque chose de qui va ruiner la
chine et la mettre à zéro
au lendement a peut-être dans une
prochaine émission olivier remercie
beaucoup c'est la fin de ce numéro merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous la
semaine prochaine en attendant vous
pouvez voir ou revoir nos précédents
numéros sur internet à l'adresse verte
et france pointe éveillant derniers mots
liés bien écouter ou allons-nous nous
arrêter après la 4g nous avons la 5g
peut-être bientôt la cij et pourquoi pas